per year yeah you can show it off at the
next Ironman concert but you had to be
at that concert
otherwise you're [ __ ] that's the one
that's my favorite yeah I got that one
in the hot black chick on top Ted Park
did that that's the I did the Korean
Zombie shirt oh really
yeah damn he's good he is good oh that's
a great [ __ ] shirt man yeah and your
eyes look efficiently walked out after
likewise Marc Maron in your shirt or the
guy from Grateful Dead matches Marc
Maron went the other way
super drugs oh yeah sobriety just went
all mushrooms he's totally the other way
that's a variety going Marc oh good you
should ask what the [ __ ] am i doing
avoiding all the best parts of life yeah
that's that's teaching me this sober
October thing is teaching me a lot dude
my bartender last night went to
O'Neill's wedding ran her nose wedding
and I was like do you mean it's out of
brewery right and uh I was like to
having non-alcoholic beer like I was
saying like it helps us social because
socially it's like everyone's drinking
you know and he goes yeah yeah he goes
sober October I'm like yeah but he
didn't know a lot of people know this
contest but he was just like I'm doing
it too did you know about it before last
night no we were gonna do it earlier or
later yeah then Bert had an Australia
thing I'm like there's no way you're
doing in Australia you can't be sober in
Australia and you can't be sober for the
Joker's cruise right and that was
November I think first we could remember
something and so we like just settled on
October so we just stumbled upon it
mm-hmm and other people have been doing
it for years apparently uh-huh how long
sober October been going on for a long
time
yeah Jamie says a long time off Mike
because he doesn't realize we're
pacquiao share a while yeah it's
apparently been doing it completely
lucked into it dude somebody I was at
the Jets game somebody sent me a beer
and I was like what and then I turned
and there's a I was like I can't and I
guess like I was trying to catch you do
from the stands Diaz things birds
drinking he does Wow yeah really it was
I think birds drinking because I saw him
the other day look guilty
[Laughter]
I think he's drinking Joe Rogan I've
wanted to so bad I actually needed a
break this time I went to sushi I told
you I went to sushi and when was I was
like oh yeah get a nice corsage hmm
I've been [ __ ] it's October god damn it
it's like it makes you realize now it's
not just casually drinking that there's
moments where booze really does go well
with an experience steak in a nice glass
of red wine yes yeah November 5th son
we're going off if I'm a fifth of our
fifth that's what I'm gonna do the recap
podcast we're all going off so Ari and I
have been battling for first place
recently until today when Tom Segura
snuck in the second place with his 400
plus points today that really puts a
pressure on me it really has hurt me to
not I finally joined a gym because of
this to blink it's a small gym but it's
like right near my 7 minute walk from my
apartment so I can pass on the way
hoping the cellar I can get a workout in
right then if I want that's good yeah
it's 24 hours as far as weekdays mmm so
work has a crazy [ __ ] life there's a
crazy life in New York - everything's 24
there's so many 24-hour things
restaurants